[موسيقى]
صباح الخير
بياني باش good morning
يسرني ايها الحضور الكريم ان التقيكم
اليوم في هذا المحفل الكريم الكبير ايضا
في طرح تجربتي في الحياه كوني ناشطه
مدنيه او ناشطه حقوقيه طيله خمسين سنه
اكثر من 50 سنه في بناء حركه مجتمع مدني
لتعزيز
المواطنه قيم المواطنه
والتعايش السلمي والتنوع
اود ان اتحدث واقول
وانا في المرحله المتوسطه ان غمرت في
الحركه الطلابيه
وحتى تخرجي من الجامعه
وانا فتاه ايضا وعيت على حقوق المراه
مبكرا
فالتحقت بعد تخرجي من الجامعه في العمل في
النضال النسوي
ايضا مبكرا حددت مسار تعليمي الجامعي
بالتوجه نحو كليه الحقوق
ورغم ممانعه الاهل او عدم رضا الاهل
لخياري
لكن بالنسبه الي كان الضروره لنيل المعرفه
من اجل تحقيق الاهداف الساميه في الحريه
والمساواه والعداله
وبهذا الشان نستنده على مقوله مهمه تتاكد
على ان الانسان اغلى قيمه في الوجود اللي
وجدتها وجدتها او وجدتها وطلعت عليها من
خلال الاديان السماويه تعاليم الاديان
السماويه وكذلك في نتاجات الفكر الانساني
الطوباوي والمدع والمادي
بنزجيت او اندمجت بالعمل الميداني وسط
الناس
وتعلمت معنى العمل التطوعي والاحساس
بالمسؤوليه وكذلك ايضا العمل بروح التضامن
مع الاخرين
انطلقت في هذا الجانب ايضا ان هناك
تاثيرات كبيره كانت على توجهي من مدرساتي
ومن زميلاتي في البصره من ابرزهن ممكن
اشير الى
الشهيد البطله الشهيد الخالده عايده ياسين
رمز رمز البطوله والفداء وكذلك مدرستي
سهام حمدي
وصديقتي كوثر عمران وامنه صادق كما افتخر
انني عاصرت وعملت مع رائدات في الحركه
النسويه العراقيه
اقول
تجربتي زادت عن الخمسين سنه مسيرته
النضاليه تجاوزت الخمسين سنه
تعلمت او مؤمنه طيله هذه السنوات
ان علينا خوض نضال مرير لتحقيق التغيير
من اجل الاهداف
نحو الرقي والتقدم
في طريق النضال الشاق
استشهد استشهد العديد من رفاقي ورفيقاتي
اللي منحوني
ايمان زادا من الايمان
والحيويه لمواصله الدرب لتحقيق اهدافنا
النبيله نحو بلد ديمق حر ديمقراطي مزدهر
طيله عملت على بناء حركه مجتمع مدني فعاله
وهذه طيله السنوات المنصريمه حركه مدني
فعاله
تعمل على
او تستند على
عمليه بناء الانسان
بالتركيز على بناء البشر قبل الحجر
وتستند على مبدا المساواه في الحقوق
والحريات العامه خاصه المساواه بغض النظر
عن الجنس او القوميه او العرق او الدين او
المذهب او المعتقد او الراي او اللون او
الوضع الاقتصادي او الوضع الاجتماعي وان
منظومه حقوق الانسان
متكامله لا تتجزا
ايضا اقول
بناء من هنا
في اربيل فيها
في
انطلقت جمعيه الامل العراقيه
كوميه هواي عراقي
اللي كمنظمه غير ربحيه حملت لواء الامل
وعملت على عمليه اعاده نشر
اعاده بناء الوعي المجتمعي ونشر ثقافه
حقوق الانسان
والعمل على ايضا
في اطار الهويه المواطنه
الحاضنه للتنوع وكذلك تقويه التعايش
السلمي في بلدنا
رؤيتنا بعد 2003
تبلورت في ضروره
بناء حركه مجتمع مدني تعمل على رسم
السياسات شريكه في رسم السياسات وتنفيذها
من اجل العداله الاجتماعيه
وهذه الجانب بالنسبه لنا انطلقنا لتعزيز
روابط التضامن والتشبيك مع المنظمات
المجتمع المدني المحليه والدوليه
انطلقنا في حملات وبرامج متنوعه
برامج توعيه مدنيه بحقوق الانسان لحقوق
المواطن وحرياته
وايضا من اجل
القضايا الاقليات
والشرائح الاجتماعيه المستضعفه
وكذلك من اجل تحقيق
المطالبه او برامج
تمكين على مستوى المجتمع المجتمعات
المحليه وعلى وفي مؤسسات الدوله وكذلك
عملنا على برامج مدافعه ومناصره بدءا من
الدستور العراقي في سنه 2005 وفي العديد
من القوانين والسياسات الوطنيه الحكوميه
في البلد حاولنا نعمل عمل متنوع كما كحركه
مجتمع مدني
نجحنا في الدستور في ادراج دعم
لمؤسسات المجتمع المدني
واستقلاليه عملها
بعد خمس سنوات ايضا
في ادارتنا لحمله الضغط والمدافعه نجحنا
ايضا ان مجلس النواب يصدر قانون
للمنظمات غير الحكوميه رقم رقم 12 لسنه
2010 اللي يشكل ضمانه قانونيه لدعم حريه
عملنا
وايضا استقلاليتنا
كما نجحنا في تثبيت
كوتا للنساء في مجلس النواب تثبيتها في
الدستور
وايضا بعد اذن اصبحت موجوده في مجالس
المحافظات
استطعنا ايضا في هذا الجانب انا اقول ان
اليوم ان المراه في مواقع صنع القرار
وايضا التصدي لمظاهر لمظاهر العنف
والتمييز ضد المراه اصبح مثبت في السياسات
الوطنيه الحكوميه هذا مهم جدا بالنسبه لنا
ايضا اشير
انه احنا يعني
اشرنا ايضا نقول اليوم احنا مع كل هذه
النجاحات هذه التجارب تعلمنا الكثير
استقينا منها دروس في النجاح والفشل
وايضا اقول واجهنا تهديدات غير قليله
لتكميم الافراح
لكن انا اليوم وهنا اقول بثقه ان منظمات
المجتمع المدني لها تاثيرها المحسوس في
معادله المواطنه والحكم الديمقراطي وايضا
لها تاثيرها في العمليه السياسيه
بتعزيز بالدفع نحو تعزيز الحوار والتفاوض
وايضا القبول بالاخر
وارساء سياده القانون
وكذلك ايضا نعرف على كيفيه
تعبئه المواطنين بالحملات الانتخابيه
وبمشاركه بالحياه العامه
كما نعمل على ايضا في نفس الوقت على
التصدي
لمظاهر الفساد
والمحاصصه وكذلك مظاهر العنف والانتهاكات
وفي
والافلات من العقاب كما لعبت منظمات
المجتمع المدني دور مهم في التضامن مع
ضحايا الارهاب والنازحين وكذلك في فتره
جائحه كورونا العصيبه
لا اغالي اذا اقول اليوم ايضا ان منظمات
المجتمع المدني لعبه دور مهم في الحركات
الاحتجاجيه في الساحات والشوارع
استنكارا للتفجيرات
والعمليات الارهابيه والمجازر الدمويه
اللي حتت في العقد الاول بعد 2003
واللي ايضا عملنا على كذلك على المطالبه
بالحقوق بين النساء والشباب
شرائح المستضعفه وكذلك في قضايا الاقليات
هذه انعكسه بصماتها ايضا على احترامي حركه
الاحتجاجات السلميه منذ 2011 واللي بلغت
اوجهه في الحراك الشعبي في 2019 و2020
اللي
شعارها البالغين شعاره البالغين نريد وطن
ونازل اخذ حقي
انها ملامح التغيير
صنعتها قوافل شهداء
وجموع المستضعفين والمحرومين
متشابكه مع عزيمه واصرار جيل الشباب
لبناء عراق مدني
تعددي
ديمقراطي يحترم حقوق الانسان وحرياته
ويعيش بسلام في اطار دوله المواطنه
والعداله الاجتماعيه
اقول ختاما
انني افتخر بكل هؤلاء
وبهم يزهو مستقبلنا وشكرا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]